[Music]
you know I'm coming
tell asana what are you going to be for
Halloween we know you like to get
dressed up and shove chocolate in your
face for fancy occasions but what do you
do when you want to scare the living
daylights out of the people of arendelle
we think you and Elsa should dress up
like zombie sisters and terrorize the
kingdom sure it's nice to be a pretty
princess but it's more fun to dress up
like a spooky monster Disney Princesses
are beautiful sweet and have lovely
singing voices but it is so much fun to
imagine them as terrifying monsters do
you ever wonder what they would look
like as scary zombies and gross gory
ghouls well lucky for us a few talented
artists have reimagined our favorite
Disney Princesses as scary monsters here
are our 10 favorites zombie Belle sure
Bela is the most beautiful princess in
the land she's got everything looks
intelligence and a good heart but what
would happen if she turned into a zombie
thanks to a tie artist who goes by the
name of clock tower man we don't have to
wonder anymore check out this cool
zombie look their artists gave Belle is
that an eyeball for an earring the tiny
skulls and her hair are a nice touch and
what a clever way to store that rose
Rapunzel listen an entire lifetime being
imprisoned in a tower can change a
person it's no wonder clock tower man
turned Rapunzel into a monster it only
makes sense that she would go so totally
insane she would turn into a scary gecko
hungry princess you can tell from her
sinister expression that she is done
with that tower she looks like a Disney
Villains worst nightmare mother Gothel
had better run fast before a monster
Rapunzel gets a hold of her now look
what you've done
puzzle snow-white have you ever asked
yourself what would snow white be like
if she turned her cute little doors into
savage flesh-hungry critters and became
the queen of those critters well the
deviant artist Jeffrey Thomas wondered
the same thing then he created this
wicked cool art piece of a dark dwarf
master with pitch black eyes and a
rotten apple she's going to be a
formidable opponent against the Wicked
Queen we don't know what's scarier this
twisted princess or those fangtooth
goblins at her side
you do not Sleeping Beauty Jeffrey
Thomas turned sweet songbird Sleeping
Beauty into something downright
terrifying she looks like a witch from
the woods who is ready to steal your
soul perhaps this is the version of the
princess who was never awakened by true
love's kiss oh I'm sorry I didn't mean
to frighten you instead she rotted in
decayed and is on a mission to destroy
Maleficent and any hopeful lovebirds who
dare approach her in the woods if she
doesn't get you her humongous owl will
Pocahontas we're not gonna lie we love
this look for Pocahontas she doesn't
even look that monstrous she just looks
like a warrior who was fed up with
settlers coming to her land and trying
to take over everything she means
business and she's got the skulls to
prove it also we're loving the scary
upgrade to raccoon and grandmother
willow nice job Jeffrey Thomas
Cinderella what would happen if you
cross the movie Coraline with Cinderella
artist Jeffrey Thomas has your answer
with this spooky rendition of Cinderella
note the button eyes that are sewn into
place
she must have nod through that pumpkin
because she doesn't have any teeth left
and instead of a cute little mouth she's
holding a scary rat with a long snout if
you like this look wait until you see
what Elsa and onna look like
sacrificed yourself for me Mulan this
Chinese princess was already someone you
don't want to mess with but Jeffrey
Thomas elevated the game with this look
Mulan has so many arrows in her she
looks like a horrifying pin cushion her
eyes are as white as snow and moo shu
have got a serious dragon upgrade sure
Mulan's friends were shocked to find out
that she was a woman there was something
wrong with you but imagine how shocked
they would be to see her like this the
Hun army would run away screaming from
this version of Mulan Ariel Ursula might
want to think twice before messing with
this twisted under-the-sea princess this
little lady has been through some things
you guys note the fort where her hand
used to be we have to wonder does she
still call it a dinglehopper a
dinglehopper and look at what artist
Geoffrey Thomas did to flounder he looks
like he ate flotsam and jetsam and is
still hungry for more we feel sorry for
any poor unfortunate soul who crosses
paths with this little mermaid Anna and
Elsa Anna and Elsa are tied for the
scariest Disney Princess monsters clock
tower man got everyone shook by his
artwork that depicts our favorite
arendelle princesses as these grotesque
zombie monsters honest chin is going to
give us nightmares for weeks and Elsa's
cheek is so gross we're loving this
disturbing take on our favorite Disney
Princesses we're just relieved that the
artist didn't include Olaf we're not
sure we could have handled that first
off would have burst into tears if he
saw onna like this and we have to wonder
if zombie Elsa would still have her ice
powers if so she would be the most
terrifying Disney Princess of them all
she must still have ice powers because
it appears that onna is holding on to
one of Elsa's ice daggers now that's a
sight we won't forget kudos to the
artist clock tower man and Jeffrey
Thomas who made these scary renditions
of our favorite Disney Princesses which
Disney Princess monster was your
favorite tell us in the comments thanks
for watching the things subscribe to our
channel to be the first to see our
latest video
and be sure to give this video a big
thumbs up see you next time
[Music]